hello everyone so how did Bobby Fischer
save Game of Thrones this was actually
an article published by chess come three
years ago so what's the idea well in in
early 1970s george RR martin was
actually well he was still a student he
was trying to make his way in the world
with his writing and well he did have to
pay the bills he had to pay the rent the
phone bills and such and well so he had
to work and he worked as a chess
tournament director he was directing
chess tournaments and that means working
only over the weekends because the
tournaments were on Saturdays and
Sundays and this didn't really you know
make him much money and it was only
after Bobby Fischer's 1972 match against
Boris Spassky that he won in Reykjavik
that chess became so popular the
popularity of just simply exploded after
that after Bobby's victory if you were
playing chess you were considered to be
cool and trendy and there was so much
demand for directing chess tournaments
that george RR martin could without a
problem work two days a week just you
know saturdays and sundays and he would
make enough money to pay his rent and
the bills and the george martin says in
in his interview that well a lot of his
friends who were also trying to become
famous writers well not famous but you
know know that had to work five days a
week and only they could only write for
two days a week over the weekends with
it when they didn't work so yeah and we
all know how long it takes george to
publish a book when he's doing it full
time so imagine how long it would take
him to to finish a song of ice and fire
or some of his previous works if he had
to work five days a week so definitely
what what enabled martin to to become a
writer as as soon as he did was just
becoming more popular and well the
reason chess became more popular is
definitely Bobby Fischer's victory over
Spassky in 1972 so yeah definitely
I really enjoyed this when I saw it and
Martin was actually a pretty good player
himself his peak rating was the 1905 and
he even founded a Chess Club he was
high school team captain and a lot of
well a lot of his work is actually based
on chess the entire Game of Thrones
series is well all tactics and strategy
and control of key territory and tyrion
lanister well not not in the show but in
the books he plays a blizzard game that
is similar to chess it's called kawase
or kvass I'm not really sure how to
pronounce it so in a lot of ways the
George Martin was influenced by the game
and he said that even though he enjoyed
chest very much when he was young he
kind of gave up on chess and committed
committed to writing full time because
just required too much work he says so
yeah definitely and definitely an
interesting story and well for the end
of this video
I prepared a very nice position for you
this is the position I thought I thought
it was already on the board this is the
position from the game Fischer Spassky
in Reykjavik in 1972 this is Game 1 of
their match and in this positions must
be played b5 so if you look at the
position it's ok both players have six
pawns they have a dark square Bishop and
if you were asked to play this game it
would probably say but this is a draw
why play this game but in this position
actually but Bobby Fischer made one of
the most of one of the most spectacular
moves ever played in in a World
Championship match me hotels move
against botany that Knight f4 move was
spectacular as well but that move won't
tell the game and this move Fischer
played this is something completely
different
he played Bishop captures on h2 and if
someone told you that someone playing
for the world title actually played this
you would say ok g3 and so what his
Bishop is trapped and this is exactly
what Spassky did but there was a whole
lot of confusion going on because Bobby
Fischer played Bishop captures on h2 and
some of the grandmasters and some of the
soviet grandmaster who were actually
saying that this is winning for black
and that Bobby must have found a win
here so the game continued h5 we have
kingi to h4 to
three king to e7 King to g2 h capture
son g3f capture son g3 and now Bishop
captures on g3 King captures and g3 and
Boris Spassky is now up a piece but he's
done two pawns
so King 36 K for King d5 Bishop e3 King
a for Bishop to c5 we have a six b6 very
important move f5 came to h4 where f4 e
captures on f-14 captures on f4 and King
to h5 and here we have a king to f5
Bishop to e3 came 34 they should have
two can get five Bishop h4 ephod now
Bishop g5 e 4 and O Bishop e3 not along
to King to go any deeper into the
position so King f6 King G for King e5
King g5 GD v can get 5 and now a 5 by
Bobby Bishop to F to G five so King
captures g5 Kings before I can get five
B for King e4 King captures in a four
and here we have King D five King B 5
and King TD 6 and in this position Bobby
Fischer resigns so a very very very
disturbing game of course his a pawn can
go down the board but this Bishop can
stop it without a problem and spots
people easily captured this beep on and
promote his pawn to Queen so yeah after
this game Bobby decided not to play the
second game as he said the cameras were
too loud and that he refuses to play
under such conditions and you you can
check what happened in some of my
previous videos I will put the video
after this video finishes so yeah that's
the game and I do hope you enjoyed this
story I mean if you were Game of Thrones
fans and also if you like just like I do
I'm sure you will enjoy it and yeah
thank you all for watching
I would like to thank Carl Hoff thank
you for a contribution to my channel I
really appreciate it and cause donation
came with a note he said today's lunch
is on me
so yeah thank you man I did have a pizza
Margarida meadow also had a couple of
bites and it was it was delicious man
thank you so that's it thanks for thank
you all for watching as usual you can
check to my previous videos here and
I'll see you soon